[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: On the back
office, perhaps we
can even create a net
new capability for HR
where we collect feedback on
our colleagues and employees
as they do their work,
and we can collate that.
We can just ping that
information to a bot
and collate that information as
we approach the review cycle.
So these are ways that chat bots
are actually being used today.
So hopefully you would agree
with some of these use cases.
So next, I want to go
through a framework that
might help developers
and executives think
about chat bots.
So first, I want to
just explain what
the different axes represent.
So on the y-axis,
you have the domain,
where you start with closed
domain chat bots that
handle one task, are very
specific to one thing,
versus open domain chat bots,
which ostensibly can talk
about anything under the sun.
So it's almost a philosophical
notion, in a way.
And then on the modeling
front along the x-axis,
you see retrieval-based bots
versus generative-based bots.
And so retrieval-based bots
retrieve pre-canned responses
or they retrieve
information from a database,
while generative bots have
actually learned something
about the data that
it was trained on,
and they're actually
generating text,
or perhaps you might
say generating speech
as a generative process.
But let's go through these
one quadrant at a time
and try to understand
a couple of examples.
So in the first
quadrant, let's take
ordering a pizza as an example.
This is pretty straightforward.
There are only so many ways
that you can order pizza.
There are only so many different
toppings that you can put on.
It has to be
delivered somewhere.
And so the point here is
that it's closed domain.
It's a pretty well-defined
task that needs to occur.
And it's retrieval-based
because these
are well-defined
conversations, and we
can retrieve an answer to
everything that the user says.
Moving along the x-axis
towards something slightly more
complex, you have
a generative model.
And so you may have
heard about Google Duplex
announced at Google I/O a
couple weeks or months back.
And this is using mostly machine
learning and deep learning.
And what it's doing is it's--
Google Duplex is able to
make restaurant reservations
and hair appointment
bookings for. you,
and it's also able to do
this in a very dynamic way.
So if you heard some of
the phone conversations,
you heard about
how dynamic it was
in being able to
book that for you.
So I'd consider that
a generative process.
But it's closed domain,
because just because it's
able to make a restaurant
reservation for me does not
mean that it can help me
assemble my Ikea furniture.
And then in the lower
left-hand corner,
this is a bit of a
thought experiment,
and so I hope I can convince
you that this is actually
impossible.
And the idea here
is that something
that's retrieval-based
cannot be open domain.
And the idea here is that you
can't anticipate everything
that the user is going
to ask you and anticipate
every response that you
would have to provide
for any conversation.
Open domain really
means just that-- we
can talk about anything.
And so I hope I
don't offend anybody
by using expert systems
here as an example.
Because the idea
behind expert systems
is to encode information
about the world
and then be able to
reason about that
and use that in
a productive way.
But there's always
something that's
not encoded in the database.
Now, to make the
point really clear--
so perhaps I go to
Fathom and say, hey,
can you get me the
bumblebee cat GIF?
And the bot says, I don't
think I've seen that one.
And I say, you never
have the latest ones.
You never have the
latest cat GIFs.
And it apologizes because
you can't possibly
keep up with everything
that a user might ask for
or every conversation
that could take place.
So hopefully that
makes the point clear.
And then moving on
from there is something
that I think a lot of people
in this room, and perhaps
at all the research
conferences, are interested in,
which is Artificial General
Intelligence, or AGI.
This is the hardest, and this is
where research is taking place.
And this would involve a
generative model, a generative
based bot that's open domain.
Now, we don't really know
how to imbibe machines
with the same qualities
that humans have.
We're very deft at
taking new information,
incorporating that into our
knowledge and understanding
of the world, and
then using that
in new and innovative ways.
And for any non-native
English speakers
here, maybe you've never
heard the word "deft" before.
But you can probably
already start
to make some predictions
that it means
in a clever, skillful way.
And it's this quality
that we don't know how
to encode into machines yet--
where you take something you've
never encountered before,
you reason about it, and you
extend your understanding
of the world.
And so an example of this,
for any Isaac Asimov fans
out there, is Robby the Robot.
And so what we're talking
about is the positronic brain.
And I say that with a
little tongue in cheek.
But yeah, this would
be an idea of something
that's artificially
generally intelligent.
So just to be clear, this
is where Fathom Bot sits.
You might argue that
something like Google,
or any kind of search-based
system, is more open domain.
But I think that needs
to be reserved for only
the most advanced systems.
So hopefully this is helpful
for, again, both developers
and business thinkers
alike in thinking
about what capabilities
they need to build
into their next chat bot.
So the bottom line
here is bots are
really powerful in
well-defined domains.
We're still figuring
out how to extend them
to many different tasks.
Now, the second
section is around
how bots are being built today.
So as promised, we just talked
about some of the use cases.
And now we'll talk
a bit about how
bots are actually being built.
But first, I think we can
go ahead and do a demo.
So this is the Fathom Bot.
And so we can start by
saying, hey, Fathom.
And what we'll get
back is a response
to corral users and
start to educate people
about how they can use the
bot and what it is useful for.
I think it's important
to educate users.
But they're definitely
going to test your bot,
and you're going
to get questions
like, how old are you.
In bot years, I'm just a kid.
And then you'll get questions
like, can you get smarter.
Yes, but it depends on
how much PwC invests.
This is currently under
active development.
And then you'll probably want
to do something more useful,
like search for one of
your colleague's profiles.
So let's take Adrian
Boda as an example.
And this is actually
his profile,
so please don't spam him.
Adrian is actually
a really nice guy.
And so then we may want to
retrieve some information
about one of our
clients or a company,
and so we can
search for Alphabet.
And we can pull back
that company card.
I'm not sure if the
internet is slow here.
There we go.
So if we wanted
to, we could then
click into that
company's profile.
And I think the end
state of something
like this would be to reason
about that information.
So what projects is
Adrian on, or what
projects do we have going
on with Alphabet right now?
And so that would
be the end state.
And this uses some
mild machine learning,
and I'll explain that when
we get back to the slides.
But now I want to show you some
more explicit machine learning
that we've used.
So if we engage the FAQ model,
I'll show you how we're-- and I
should be clear that we've
just engaged a certain intent.
And I'll explain that
when we're talking
about building these bots.
But maybe we have
a question that you
might find in an FAQ sheet.
And so what we might
ask about is CEO action
on diversity and inclusion.
Because PwC has been really
focused on this this year.
Our CEO has been really
front and center on this.
And so what you
see is that we're
matching on a number of
similar questions and answers
in our question and answer base.
And so the idea here
is that we can directly
address users' questions without
having to have them click
around in the search portal.
And so this is using
machine learning.
We've matched on this question.
It gives you the answer,
cites its source.
And then this is really an
artifact of development,
but it just gives
you this notion
of there is a goodness of
fit or a goodness of match
that you can discern
how confident you are
in putting forward the answer.
So I'll mention that when
I talk about thresholds.
But what I'm really
excited to show
you guys today is something
that I think really
moves the user experience.
And if I do a general
search for something
related to
international tariffs,
because that's making
a lot of headlines
lately, what it's
going to do is it's
going to go and retrieve
a bunch of articles
from the Fathom database.
It's not able to connect
to the Fathom database.
I'll give it one more try.
Sorry, guys.
What's the first
rule of live demos?
Don't do them.
I'll give it one
more try, but I don't
want to belabor the
point, because I'll
talk a bit more about it
later in the presentation.
I'm also thinking that
this is public right now,
and I'm wondering if there
are people in the audience
or remotely that are
actually hitting this bot
and just overloading
it right now.
I thought that
was a possibility.
I was just testing this
before I came up here.
Let's try it one last time.
Well, apologies for that.
So what I was going
to try to show
was the ability to
do a general search.
We retrieve some
documents, and then we
ask a follow-up question
about those documents.
And so this uses a machine
comprehension model.
And so I'll talk a
bit more about that
as we move through
the presentation.
So I think with that, we
should probably just move back
to the slides.
OK.
So a bit about
what you just saw.
These are the four
things that you're
going to have to solve
for no matter what
bot that you're building.
And so this is a bit of
a conceptual framework,
and I think it's helpful for
any developer to understand.
So starting with
intent detection, what
I'll do when I go
through these slides
is I'll talk a bit
about the challenge
that we're talking about.
A bit about--
I'll show you an example and
then talk about a few solutions
using vendor solutions
or open source solutions
if that's more your speed.
So for this example,
the intent detection
is what does the user want.
So if we're looking for the
weather, it's just that.
The intent is to
get the weather.
If you look at this example
on the screen, info on Adrian
Boda, it is intent
classification
where you're trying to determine
what the user is looking for.
And it's not a company search.
It's not a people search.
Or it's not a company
search or a general search.
It's a people search.
And so if you think about that,
it's just a text classification
task.
And you can use your favorite
text classification pipeline,
TFIDF to random forest.
Or if you have more
data, you might
go with something more
sophisticated, like an LSTM.
Or if you don't want to
build something like that,
you can use something--
rules-ish-based approach,
like Dialogflow, or the
NLP API, which hopefully I
can explain on the next slide.
So the second challenge is
going to be entity extraction.
What information do we need
to extract from the text
in order to be able to
fulfill the request?
And so what we see here
is-- and then one sub-bullet
on that is can we
rely on dialogue
flow for proper nouns, so
people, places, and things
like that.
Because you have to
train the Dialogflow
agent to be able to
detect these proper nouns.
And it's very difficult to
enumerate all of the employees
at your company in Dialogflow.
And so here are two ways that
this may go off the rails.
In the first example, somebody
might say info on Adrian Boda.
And maybe you get the intent,
which is to query for a person,
but you don't
extract the entity,
which is underlined in red.
And so one solution here
is to use follow-ups.
So you might say,
hey, I think you're
looking for people search,
but I didn't get the name.
So what name are
you looking for?
And then you can
proceed that way
when the user provides the name.
Another situation is where you
don't have a lot of contacts
at all, and you're working
with proper nouns, something
like Alphabet.
You might not get the
intent or the entity.
And so one solution here is to
use something like the NLP API.
So you head out to
the NLP API, determine
what entity was extracted.
And if it's an
organization, you now
have the company that
you're searching for
as well as the intent,
which is a company search.
And so what we're
talking about here
is named entity recognition
models, or NER models.
And Dialogflow
does this natively.
The NLP API does this natively.
But if you're more into
the open source scene,
the Stanford NER
Tagger or Spacey
or any number of
open source tools
will allow you to
accomplish this task.
The next challenge
is state management.
The idea here is where are
we in the conversation.
And anytime you have
a conversation that
takes on more than one turn--
in other words, the user asks a
question like-- and by the way,
this was what I was
going to try to show,
was where you have a search
like international tariffs.
It finds some
documents and asks,
do you have any
additional questions.
I say yes.
And then we ask about--
I don't know-- what
are the implications
of international tariffs
on manufacturing.
And then it will give
you a direct answer.
Now, I also want to mention that
machine learning hasn't really
been able to solve this yet.
And so I'll link you to a paper
here called "End-to-End Task
Completion Neural
Dialogue Systems"
where they attempt to use
a fully differentiable deep
learning model to be able
to solve the task of booking
a movie ticket.
And it's with mixed results.
So I guess that brings
me to the solutions.
Dialogflow is terrific
for this, architecting
these conversational flows.
And then another thing
that I'll mention
is Mongo or some sort
of external store.
You can imagine interacting
with your user across time
and across multiple platforms.
And so you need some notion of
cache or persisting that user's
profile across interactions.
And then the final
thing is hopefully
machine learning will
make some advances
in this in the near
question mark future.
The final challenge to be solved
for any bot, assuming it's
retrieval-based-- so the
distinction I made earlier
would be retrieval-based
versus generative-based models.
When you think about
information retrieval,
there are two sources
of information.
One is structured sources.
The other is unstructured.
And so structured sources
are things like CSV files.
You can think of them like
SQL queries or API calls.
But unstructured sources require
a bit more deep learning,
machine learning, data science.
And that's the stuff
that I get excited about.
And so what you see here is
an unstructured text document.
And that was really the
focus of our project, which
was to retrieve information
from unstructured text sources,
so similar to the way that
I was showing the FAQ model,
where we're able to
answer questions as such.
And so some solutions here
are to use machine learning
models and deep learning models,
or even something more naive,
like a TFIDF model,
if you have less data.
And then some of the easier
ones are SQL queries and API
queries.
And I'll also call out QANet,
because that was the model
that we had running in our
Fathom Bot, which is a machine
comprehension model.
Google published that
paper a few months back.
And I think it's still number
one on the squad leader board.
And I'll explain a bit
more about all that
in just a moment.
So this is probably why a lot
of you guys attended this talk.
And so I want to take
a moment to just talk
through the architecture
and what this actually
looks like on Google Cloud.
Starting with the user in
the upper right corner,
the user is trying to
interact with Dialogflow.
They make a hop to
App Engine, which
makes the call to Dialogflow.
And Dialogflow evaluates
the user's request,
determines how to route it,
determines what information
needs to be extracted
out of that,
and then sends that to what
I call the broker, which is
this guy right in the middle.
And this is a bit
of a Russian doll.
We have a Python Flask
app running in Docker,
running on Kubernetes.
And so I'm sure this is a pretty
common design pattern for some
of the folks in this room.
But what I really like is
the elasticity of this.
And so the idea
here is that you get
all the benefits of
the horizontal scaling
as more users come online.
And so the idea--
I guess I should
be clear and say
that the broker's
responsibility is
to ping all these different
APIs, to go out and do
fulfillment, as it's called, in
the Dialogflow documentation.
And so one source of
fulfillment is the PwC database,
where we're retrieving
some of that information
about our colleagues and
companies and clients.
And then we also have
some GPU-enabled instances
running on Kubernetes.
So we've got some
TensorFlow models
running on GPU-enabled instances
for some of these tasks,
like information retrieval,
question answer models.
And then finally, you can use
external storage like Mongo,
or you might even
hack it with something
like Cloud Storage, where you're
just retrieving information
based on conversation IDs.
So this is, in short,
what is architected
on the Cloud platform.
And a couple of tips that might
be useful to somebody that's
going down this road--
once you understand
what Dialogflow does,
I would encourage you to look at
the Python Dialogflow package.
Once you really understand
what Dialogflow does,
you can and should script just
about everything with respect
to bot creation and updates.
Gcloud is obviously
a great tool.
It's your friend.
You can use it to build
these Kubernetes clusters.
You can basically
use it to build
your entire infrastructure.
And so I would
definitely encourage
that to be your source of
documentation versus creating
documentation sheets
where somebody
has to go into the user
interface and click around.
It's just too prone to
error, as we've found.
Establish a robust
testing framework.
So this becomes a
quite complex system.
What happens is you've got a
noisy input coming from users.
Dialogflow is evaluating that.
You're trying to
understand how Dialogflow
is going to behave under
various circumstances,
and then you're
trying to understand
how fulfillment
is going to behave
under certain circumstances.
So you need to really have
a robust testing framework
to understand where things
might be going off the rails,
if and when they do.
And then finally, on team
Docker and Kubernetes,
I probably don't have to
say much more on that.
But I just like it as
a development pattern.
So the key things here
are machine learning
is already pretty present
in most chat bots today,
and GCP has all the
necessary tools to do this.
So now let's move into some
of the intelligence layer,
as I was discussing before,
with machine learning.
And again, as promised, we've
talked about some use cases.
We've talked a bit about
how bots are actually built.
And now we're going to talk a
bit about how machine learning
is layered into this bot.
So these were three
information retrieval tasks
that we thought about
during this project.
And so what are each
of these in a word?
So document retrieval--
you've got a query,
and you're looking for
relevant documents.
It's basically what Google does.
We have a query like
international tariffs.
We should be able to
retrieve documents at PwC
that are related to this query.
The second task,
question answering,
is taking questions that you
might see on an FAQ document,
and being able to take a query,
and find a similar question
or find the answer
to that user's query.
So an example would
be, what should I know
about international tariffs.
And the response would
be the matched question,
so what tariffs
have been proposed,
which it was matched to.
And then ultimately, the
user is looking for something
like this, like the answer.
And then machine
comprehension, which
I think is the most
sophisticated of all these,
is where you're answering
a user's question
by retrieving a very
specific span of text
from some unstructured
text document.
So an example was--
and this is what I wanted
to show during the demo,
but the query would
have been something
like, what should manufacturers
prepare for after tariffs.
And the response would
be something like,
higher material costs.
So again, these were
three of the tasks.
We focused on the latter two,
so question and answering
and machine comprehension.
So we can double click
into each of those
to get a better sense of how
we're actually building that.
So question answering-- there's
two ways to think about it.
One is question to question,
where you're using something
like a TFIDF-based
model, and you can just
measure the cosine similarity
between two vectors,
and you'll get something
like a match score.
And the idea here is you
take a question like this,
and you match it to
all of the questions
that you have in your
database, and you
look for the best match.
And then by default,
you just have the answer
as your lookup value.
So that's hopefully
pretty straightforward.
Now, the other way of
thinking about it--
and this is often when
you have more data.
And we've trained models
with hundreds of thousands
of examples, and we've seen
deep learning models start
to really excel here where
you go from a question
to an answer.
So the user says something
like, what should I
know about
international tariffs,
and you're trying to
match to an answer.
And so the deep
learning model is
going through the
answer column now
and trying to match that query
to the appropriate answer.
And I think this is probably
obvious for a number of folks,
but you might want
to cite your source
and any other information that
might be helpful to the user
to be able to do their
own further investigation.
Now, the final
piece of this talk
is around machine comprehension.
And I really like
the way that one
of the co-authors of the
SQuAD paper described it.
And he says it's "the ability
to read a piece of text
and then answer
questions about it."
And this is really
challenging for machines.
And to be clear, the SQuAD paper
refers to the Stanford Question
Answering Dataset,
which has become
the de facto benchmark for
machine comprehension models.
And so QANet, as I
mentioned earlier, I think,
is still ranked number
one for that dataset.
And so again, to be
abundantly clear,
we're talking about
selecting an answer span
from a provided text passage.
And so if we look at the
picture on the right, which
is taken from the SQuAD paper,
you see there's a passage.
These are Wikipedia articles.
And then the users have
posed a bunch of questions
against that article.
And they've also
highlighted the answer.
And so the first
question is, what
causes precipitation to
fall, answer being gravity.
And you can see that
it's listed up above.
And so that should also
tell you how these datasets
are structured where you
have a passage, a query,
and an answer.
And with that, we can build
machine learning models
to take in passages
and questions,
and hopefully put
forward what it thinks
is the most likely answer.
And so for anyone
that thinks they've
solved the task of
machine comprehension,
I would encourage you to take
a look at this question here,
which says, "which technology
was developed most recently?"
And to us, the
answer is obviously
A, the cellular telephone.
But for the guy on the left,
this is a difficult task.
We don't really know how
to imbibe machine learning
models with this notion of
common sense or real world
reasoning.
And the information is there.
We just don't really
know how to encode it
into these machine
learning models,
whereas it's very trivial for
the guys on the right, which
is a picture from the
movie "Dumb and Dumber."
And I'll leave you with
one little nugget here.
If you're interested
in these topics,
I really enjoy listening to a
podcast called "Data Skeptic,"
hosted by a guy
named Kyle Polich.
And he did an episode
called "The Imitation Game"
where he interviewed
some folks from the Allen
Institute and talks about
this dataset and this task.
Fresh off the press--
last month's SQuAD,
the SQuAD team,
released a second dataset.
And I think they're addressing
what I think is a pretty
important problem, which is
to abstain when presented with
a question that
cannot be answered.
In other words, if the model
is not confident enough
or couldn't find the answer
in the provided text passages,
we need to know that
we're not confident enough
to put forward the answer.
And right now, I'm having to
use things like thresholds
to be able to
determine if I've got
enough information to
answer the question
or not, or if I'm confident
enough to answer that question.
So for any
practitioners out there,
you know that transfer learning
can only take you so far.
SQuAD was from the
Wikipedia domain.
I'm working in the PwC domain.
So transferring a model
train on Wikipedia
will only take me
so far for PwC.
Labeling data is expensive.
So as much as I'd love $20,000
to go out to Mechanical Turk
and label a bunch
of data, I'm not
going to get approved for that.
And so we need to
think about how
we generate data in either
a semi-supervised or a fully
unsupervised way.
And so what I want to
share here is something
that we would be exploring
if we had more time.
And this paper is called
[? "Sin ?] [? Net." ?] And
if you look at the 1, 2,
and 3 on the screen here,
the idea here is that we
can take the SQuAD data set.
We've got the passages, the
questions, and the answers.
And we can train the model to
generate interesting questions
and answers given the passage.
And we know what those
questions and answers are
because we have labeled data.
So once we train a
model to do that,
we can feed in PwC documents,
and take those passages,
and generate questions and
answers in the PwC domain.
And then you close
the training loop
by going back to the
machine comprehension model
and fine-tuning that model
on a combination of the SQuAD
data and the PwC data
to be able to bring
that model into the PwC domain
and perform a little bit
better.
So these are the
things that you have
to think about on
a day to day to be
able to actually get these
machine learning models
up and running.
So I think hopefully, that
was convincing that machine
learning models can
and should improve
information
retrieval, especially
for unstructured documents.
So some final
considerations here--
what data can you collect?
So for the FAQ documents,
we had to round up
all these FAQ sheets and then
parse out those documents,
extract out the
questions, the answers.
And I think we wound
up with something
like 20,000
question-answer pairs
that we can then train our
machine learning models with.
I just talked a
couple of slides back
about the need to
generate or label
data in some circumstances.
These are some things that
you will have to think about.
And then how can we improve
the quality of our results
from user feedback?
So if we're open to capturing
user feedback, was this useful
or not, how do we then close
the model training loop
and incorporate that into
our model, improve results?
On the user front,
how confident are
that we have the right answer?
And this comes back to the
notion of thresholding,
where you have a
probability score associated
with a lot of these models.
And that should be
tuned to determine
the number of false positives
and also the amount of volume
that you can handle
for incoming queries.
Be clear about what the
bot can and can't do.
So when I first started
interacting with the bot,
it said I'm helpful for
people queries, company
queries, general searches.
And so you have to
coach users, because I
think the expectations
are set very high,
And I think you're definitely
set up to disappoint users
if you're not clear enough.
Consider edge cases.
So your users will try to
push the bots to its limits,
and you just want to
understand how it's going
to behave in those edge cases.
And this is for a number of
data scientists out in the room.
I think we all do a good
job defining measures
of intrinsic evaluation--
so accuracy score,
recall at k, F1 scores, exact
match, all that fun stuff.
But we also need to
think about measures
of extrinsic evaluation.
So how have we moved the needle
for the business in terms
of user time saved,
number of clicks
reduced to find a
piece of information,
or potentially even revenue?
So if I've done my job
well, this is where you are.
We've talked about
some use cases, how
bots are being built today, and
a bit about the intelligence
layer.
That concludes
this talk, and I'm
happy to take
questions at this time.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]